>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> BARD Express: Browsing
the BARD Collection.
>> Judy: Hello, I'm Judy Dixon,
Consumer Relations Officer at NLS.
In this edition of the
BARD Express How-To Series,
I'm going to cover browsing
the BARD collection.
BARD Express gives you many options
for browsing available materials.
You can browse by series, browse
by subject, or browse magazines.
To browse by series, from the BARD
Express Main Menu select browse
by series.
You will be presented with a list
of series available in
the BARD collection.
Note that you are going to
land in the list of series
and the focus will be
on the first series
in the list of more than 4,000.
To find a particular series,
tab to the edit box and type
in the name of the series.
For example, I am going to
search for the Alex Cross Series.
Tab to the list of series
containing the words Alex Cross
and use the arrow up and down keys
to find the one you are looking for.
Select the series title to
access the books in the series.
>> NVDA: Loaded Browse by Series:
Alex Cross series: items 1 to 23.
Browse by series.
Alex Cross Series.
Press F1 for Help List
Along came a spider.
Author Patterson, James.
Series Alex Cross Series 01 of 23.
>> Judy: The available books
in the series will be
presented in a list view.
The focus will be on the
first book in the list.
Use the arrow up and down
keys to browse the list.
From this screen you can add titles
from the series to your wish list,
download them, or access
their details.
Additionally, you may change
the sort order of the book list.
If you are going to download
or add to your wish list more
than one title in this series, I
recommend you use the advanced view.
Switch to the advanced view using
the keyboard shortcut control L.
Then select the titles you wish
to download using the spacebar.
In this example, we are going to
download the first three books
in the Alex Cross series
by selecting the titles
and activating the download button.
>> NVDA: Along came a spider,
check box selected not checked
Author Patterson, James checked.
Kiss the girls: a novel, check
box selected not checked Author.
Patterson, James.
Checked. Jack and Jill: a novel,
check box selected
not checked Author.
Patterson, James.
Checked. Download button.
Alt plus D. There are
now 3 items downloading.
Multi-line.
[download status beeps]
Browse by Series.
Alex Cross Series.
[download noises] Browse by Series.
Press F1 for help list.
Jack and Jill.
Author Patterson, James.
Downloads are complete.
>> Judy: Once your downloads are
complete your books will be stored
on your BARD Express
bookshelf until you are ready
to transfer them to a cartridge.
In addition to browsing the
BARD collection by series,
you may also use BARD Express to
browse the collection by subject
by selecting Browse by
Subject from the main menu
or browse the magazine collection
by selecting browse
magazines from the main menu.
For more information on
transferring books, searching BARD,
and managing your wish list see
the other tutorials in this series.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.